one thing I'm noticing is obviously on
the left particularly Warren
particularly Kamala Harris and some of
these other candidates they're appealing
to what would we would traditionally
call identity politics Trump himself is
appealing to a very specific kind of
identity politics which i think is the
only acceptable identity politics in
America that is to the American identity
he holds a big 4th of July parade he
supports the American flag hot dogs and
baseball on the 4th of July I mean it's
a very considered white supremacist now
though they're now calling that white
supremacist and he's managed to get his
opponents to protest the American flag
that when you put that on a debate stage
and you've got these narrow interest
groups and identity politics all
opposing the flag and Donald Trump
wrapping himself up like it's the 4th of
July for a national campaign that seems
to be the winning hand and you see how
popular these guys that the members of
the squad are I mean you see there was
that poll couple weeks ago maybe a week
ago with Ilhan Omar at 9% 9% that wasn't
a typo with with swing voters and then a
OC is that 22% I mean these are not
popular people these are not popular
ideas that they're profiting you know
what's amazing so president Trump he's a
New York guy right he he donated to
Democrats for years he's like not very
ideological when he decides to identify
as a Republican all of a sudden they
call him a white supremacist a bigot all
of you no evidence whatsoever he has
repeatedly said racism is evil white
nationalism is evil not neo-nazi all on
and on and on does it three times a week
Ilhan Omar is asked repeatedly you've
said some sympathetic comments about Al
Qaeda would you mind condemning al Qaeda
she won't do it how hard is it I don't
know how hard is it for her to say I
condemn how kind of all she's always
like that's a ridiculous question well
of it so ridiculous just say no yes this
about by easy we're not asking her
because she's black Somalian Muslim
we're not asking for any of those
reasons we're asking because she giggles
about al Qaeda on video she tries to get
judges to give Isis terrorists lenient
sentences she's constantly saying things
9/11 some people did something I mean
that's the thing you know just like one
time condemning she can't do it no she
can't and and and that is I think what
Americans see
and what makes America I mean even if
even if the president shouldn't have
written in that tweet or said you know
she needs they need to go back to where
they came from the reason why that is
resonating the reason why Trump's
support among Republicans went up after
that tweet is because I think it hits on
something that a lot of Americans
identify with which is that when you
have people bash in the country when you
have people who you don't know whether
they have sympathies with terrorist
organizations
there's nothing mainstream about that
and you know they painted it only in a
racial way or in which is kind of funny
because only one of them was actually an
immigrant right right in this country
but you could say the same comment to
Bernie Sanders who's an old white man or
Jewish man say go back to where you came
from
you'd be referring to the Soviet Union
right because their ideas are
anti-american ideas
socialism this country is hopelessly
bigoted we can't possibly all live
together in harmony
we all are simply separate interest
groups based on our immutable innate
characteristics those are anti-american
ideas and Trump is identifying that
they're anti-american and I think it's
resonating with certainly with
Republican voters yeah I think you're
right and I think even though none of
the members of the so-called squad are
actually running for president their
ideas are the ones that all of the
presidential candidates are asked to
respond to you know when they ask about
health care for illegal immigrants that
wasn't a mainstream idea but yet all the
hands shoot up when they asked about
that I mean that wasn't a mainstream
media that wasn't a mainstream idea
before you know a OC and the you know
whatever they call himself Democratic
Socialist became popular so the reason
why I think Trump really has it in the
bag already for 2020 is because these
loony loony ideas are the ones on the
Democrat stage right now and they they
have become the face of the Democratic
power